and uh i know since you're watching
trash taste you're i'm i'm guessing a
lot of you are weebs right i'm guessing
i'm guessing maybe maybe i don't know
this i don't know huh we're going with
this
do you would you would you talking about
we've told we've talked about how
akihabara is overrated right yeah or how
we think it is but i feel like it still
is
one of the best places to go if you just
have like a day or two in tokyo and
you've never been to japan before right
because i feel like there's nothing that
really beats that first day akihabara
experience because yes
yes you can get figures
for a better price online or other
places what's the magic it's the magic
yeah it's the magic right it's like it's
like disneyland but for weebs yeah it's
the fact that literally every billboard
and building you see around you is
covered in anime yeah which is like not
really a place you can experience
anywhere else in the world or rather
anywhere else in japan yeah exactly it's
kind of out of the way it's a little
annoying to get there i'd say i mean
it's like what like 15 minutes from
tokyo station yeah i'd say if you're
going to stay anywhere stay around
shinjuku shibuya you want a fun time
yeah yeah yeah i'd say shinjuku's
probably has the most stuff nearby yeah
[Music]
yeah yeah all that kind of stuff and
then you have the akihabara side of
tokyo which you have to do quite easily
yeah yeah which you can just cut
straight across to has like you know
asakusa you know
like you can easily spend a day in
akihabara oh easy like easily
like every time i go to akihabara even
today i still find new [ __ ] to do yeah
exactly whether you like retro games
anime figures uh
classic stuff you know like really old
transformers stuff or
any kind of otaku stuff is that made
cafes
you should be helping them yes go to a
maid camp have you been home caffeine
absolutely not yeah you don't wanna i
can tell people to go we've got we've
gone down like i can get an affiliate
here's the thing there are way cooler
themed bars in japan and in akihabara
than maid cafe you've been to a bunch
corner and like so many yeah you've been
to so many and like you know you guys
you guys have made videos about it um
sydney's making videos about it as well
like everyone wants to go to a maid cafe
but i feel like the maid cafe is like
the most basic themed cafe you could
possibly go to when there are experience
that i haven't had but i'm okay not
having i i've perhaps can have it i've
had the experience and i have had a much
funner time going to like the other
themed bars because because wouldn't
make caffeine i feel like it's an
afternoon thing it is an afternoon thing
but it's always
it doesn't matter it's just cringe yeah
but yeah like i hated it i just want
people go it's also why do you want to
see people go because i want to see
people yeah i want them to stay in
business right i don't know that they're
dying right they're dying at the moment
i want them to stay in business but i
don't want to be the one giving them
music
it's a cultural icon
it is a cultural icon but i feel just
give them your jokes
yeah i feel with the amount of like
other themed places in japan and japan
is very good at doing theme like bars
and restaurants and stuff like that yeah
i just feel like
maid cafes are kind of just becoming
like old at this point yeah because like
you know what to expect at a maid cafe
yeah but you don't know what to expect
at like i don't know like a lockdown a
lockout or you know any of those like
really cool you know kind of hidden
underground like bars and cafes right
it's lockout yeah a lockout is this
prison themed uh
restaurant that i've been to a few times
where is it uh there's a couple there is
one in shinjuku i believe oh i think i
basically go underground through a
haunted house and then you end up and
you eat inside of a cage this is what
they scream half the time yeah they
think that's the show i think i went
there and i thought the food was like
the worst food i've ever had in my life
no the main cafe it was a million times
like i i i feel like the maid cafe food
i don't know why it's just
100 of the time it's horrible food i
mean it's on par with
like you know things rice
we only we only think it's good food
because a cute girl made it no no i
don't think it's cute no but most people
feel that way well the cute girl made us
a must be good see and everything's
overpriced as well yeah you know it's
everything's overpriced and it's like 20
bucks for the most mid-autumn rice i've
ever had yeah yeah yeah yeah right
you know you get a good omer rice though
i mean if you want like a brand one yeah
yeah roll host and they do a good deal
this is like the denny's like deluxe
yeah it's like so fancy and the prices
are like ridiculous this is this is what
i feel denny's wished it was
like like going to japan and just going
to a maid cafe with all the themed bars
that are all cafes that are available
it's like going to america to for a
burger joint and going to mcdonald's or
some [ __ ] like that you know that's
right that's that's like you like you
can you have to care
you have so much choice of so many
different themes and different unique
concepts and then you go to a maid cafe
where they do the momo beam on your food
and call it a [ __ ] day that's it
that's it thank you thank you for 50
dollars
and uh you know if uh there's there's a
lot more places than you can go to
through to a maid cafe also i want to
[ __ ] die when i go to a major just go
to may cafe at your local con it's
probably the same experience it actually
is actually honestly the same
it's honestly the same except the only
difference is that the one in japan you
probably won't understand what they're
saying half the time exactly that's the
only difference yeah all right but uh
yeah i mean i understand when you're at
all majors i don't want to get out it's
just i want to go i'm far too british to
like i'm like i want to see you at a
main cafe you and you and chris and the
maid cafe you and chris and the main
cafe would be the best
that's too much cringe
yeah i mean i mean like i'm i even i'm
more attuned to like the anime culture
and stuff and i'm just like i can't
handle no i couldn't handle
i think i'd rather be seen at a strip
uh
it
club or something like that i would i i
would yeah
i think i feel like that's less normal
yeah
more normal yeah more normal but yeah i
mean like obviously get akihabara out of
your system because you're go you're
going to go you're going to want to go
to akihabara yeah you are going to have
a good time yeah and uh if you're
looking for you know places to go then
just look at our figure special you know
that's that's we basically curated our
figure special to the places that we
like to shop in nakihabara um are there
any other shops you would recommend in
akihabara that they go to oh god this is
so mean why me
what's what i like
super potato is really good that's the
retro game place that's like what's the
dojin store
there's melon books which are two
different ones uh both are good yeah
that's melon books i think has like four
entire flaws of just doujin stuff so if
you like that then go for it but
has a better selection in my opinion
yeah i think so and that one has like
seven floors or something that is like
seven or eight floors yeah and there's
two buildings as well yeah yeah exactly
um yeah because like a lot of akihabara
is you go into a store and it looks like
a one it looks like it's just a
one-story store because it's like a
[ __ ] tiny right uh it's full of stuff
and then you go in and then you realize
they have stairs and then you go up the
stairs and you realize there's another
set of stairs and you just you realize
that it just keeps going up and up and
up and up so a lot of suddenly you're in
a mob
basically and also like the best thing i
think about akihabara especially when
you go into like the really like small
building unmarked buildings is that each
of the floors is usually a different
store entirely so you could be in a
figure store at one point you go up the
stairs and then suddenly you're in an
idol shop and next moment you're in a
retro game shop yeah yeah exactly this
moment you're in a tech shop and it's
all in one building and it's yeah great
yeah that's why you can literally spend
like hours just in one random building
that you stumbled into
um and of course like the arcades there
as well because if you want to go to
japan i highly like you have to go to
the arcades there's this oh go to the
sega ones because they have the [ __ ]
mech pilot game dude that [ __ ] yeah yeah
what's that one called i can't remember
but maybe don't go to the other ones in
north carolina because like most of them
are gone yeah yeah
all the sega buildings there's a ton of
sega buildings outside of akihabara oh
yeah yeah they have like good games but
uh but the one in zanaki happened have a
lot of like vintage games yeah they have
typing of the dead still they still got
that yeah they have a they have an
entire building that just has like an
entire floor full of like old school
ladies crazy taxi it's got a few other
games got time crisis two or three which
one you play a game on the arcades for
like 50 yen i think yeah yeah it's like
really like most most arcade games are
just a hundred yen which is uh
there's uh the
old uh retro game oh yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah it was dope as [ __ ]
which is also actually shinjuku so yeah
yeah uh it's called just type in arcade
place takadenobaba yeah yeah um and yeah
like i still think like my favorite
arcade game is the mecca pilot game so
there is have we talked about it we've
mentioned it before but again we don't
know the name yeah it's literally like a
hydraulic mech
you'll see it because you literally are
piloting a mech right you'll see people
like [ __ ] tilting and [ __ ] yeah
yeah so it's kind of like reminds me of
um these old-school like rides you see
in malls or sometime or something where
it's like you're you're put into like a
capsule and you're like it's like a
roller coaster and like the uh
the capsule like tilts along with like
the roller coaster like 4d yeah like 4d
that you're seeing so imagine that
except you control the roller coaster
okay so when you when you when you pilot
this mech it'll tilt with you know it'll
tilt and curve uh when you accelerate
you feel like the acceleration and
everything it's
it's so cool it's if you're a mecha fan
or even if you're not it literally is
the closest you will ever come to
piloting a giant robot and it's pvp and
it's pvp as well and it's also like a
hundred yen yeah yeah it's like it's
like five minutes a game yeah yeah it's
really good it's battle royale but uh if
you are gonna go to the arcade you
probably should look at like a tutorial
about how to get like the cards
and everything like that because some of
them progress some of them no like some
of the games they will not let you go
past the tutorial stage if you don't
have a card like basically you pay the
money every rhythm game yeah basically
every rhythm game like if you don't have
a card um you're you're basically just
stuck at the at the tutorial level i
should be a card printer in the building
if it's a big arcade
yeah most of the bigger ones have it so
if you don't have a card just go to a
big one and there should be a machine
that prints cards and they all have
there's like three different ones though
you need to figure out which ones which
it's really confusing i'm sure there's a
guide online i'm sure yeah also if
you're having trouble what the [ __ ] is
being said on screen i just hold up
google translate to the screen and
genuinely it works yeah yeah actually
that is a good le that is a google
translate is it's not perfect but it
will give you the gist of everything
yeah it will be your best friend
basically you should use it yeah google
translate i didn't know this until i
moved to japan where google translates
has a uh camera option where it will
live translates things that you put
through the camera of google translate
uh it's been a lifesaver for me in a lot
of places here in japan
yeah exactly and uh if you ever in a
restaurant where it's all in japanese
then google translate camera will be
your best friend unless it's handwritten
and [ __ ] unless it's handwritten uh
and then you just got it blindly and
then you just gotta hope that you're
with joey and the uh he'll translate
everything for you i just say
also sue me i asked for their
recommendations and i'm like rolling the
dice yeah please for the love of god to
give me something good when i usually
it's good probably normally it's
normally one time they gave me chicken
carpaccio that was interesting oh wow
raw chicken raw chicken raw chicken uh
chicken sashimi
yeah that was that was i was like damn
what a what a great recommendation
can't wait to get salmonella yeah